hey y'all
movie retrospective time doing something
a little bit different this time out
doing an anime yeah it's a good one this
is the first time we've done this right
how i got the idea to do this one which
is wicked city
from 1987. kind of a well-known one i
had never seen this
for many reasons which which we will get
into
i think i actually first heard of this
on
brandon tennold's show because he did a
review of this
a while back and he also did a review of
the live action version which came out
in 1992 which i might get into a little
bit too
but um so i was like man that looks
pretty [ __ ] up and even though i'm not
super into anime um
it just looked like a really cool
looking movie and then i noticed when i
was
going through making lists for all the
you know movie retrospective
polls i saw that wicked city was
available on 2b for free even though
it's the dubbed version
so i don't know how you feel about that
it's like obviously yes it would be
better to watch the japanese version
that's subtitled
but you know the english dub version is
fine it's you know the dub is a little
distracting but it always is
less i think it's less distracting with
animation
than the live action because the mouse
the mouse don't line up anyway right
exactly that's what i'm saying so it
doesn't bother me
i'm real picky about anime a lot of
anime that i used to watch
you know in the 90s and the 80s was just
incoherent
you know there was a couple of them that
the stories were pretty straightforward
you could follow it
but one of the ones i remember was go go
13. i really like that one kind of like
a japanese james bond slash
mafia assassin type guy that was a
pretty good one um
but even akira i saw that and there was
the the plot to akira is kind of
convoluted
the japanese well there's a big
difference in storytelling in the west
and
and the east the east kind of have a
different structure to the stories that
they tell and from our point of view
it's not it's not it's not traditional
like three-act type stuff like
shakespearean
yeah it's more like episodic yeah that's
just the way they do [ __ ]
this one's a little bit like that but
not quite as much not as bad
um the this one's pretty good it's it's
uh it's basically it's a lot the tone is
a lot like blade runner
yeah and the look of it is kind of it's
very much inspired by blade running
imagine blade runner
but it's dealing with aliens alien sex
demons not aliens but they're they're
sex demons from another dimension
and they're kind of like the thing from
the thing yeah so it's like blade runner
the thing and hentai porn
yeah and it's kind of pro i think it's
early kind of hentai it hasn't hasn't
gone full blown
i would think that in 87 this would have
been
really cutting edge and really really
wild oh yeah um
kind of tame by today's standards of
what they make now
and hinting that hand-tied stuff that's
like a porn segment
you know and it's just not this is
pretty popular
it's pr well it's it has some
pornographic scenes in it kind of
but it's not a porn it teeters on the
edge yeah but it does have a story and
yeah some of the scenes are there's
tentacles
there is all kind of extra dimensional
sex
demons raping each other in the form of
damn spiders and
all kinds of weird [ __ ] happens melting
boobies yeah
chest [ __ ] chest [ __ ] tooth [ __ ]
just everything all this [ __ ]
weirdest [ __ ]
and like one of the characters looks
just like i i was calling him sex
gollum huh no that's sex column yeah i
mean
he was drawn kind of like gollum from
the old animated
uh uh yeah yeah from the all the from
the hobbit front no not the one after
that lord
of the rings yeah the old lord of the
rings kind of like that's if he had a
little mustache here and i'm going is
that a human
i guess he was supposed to be a human no
remember he was he was uh oh
i don't know that's right that's right
okay yeah that's right i forgot a hybrid
between a human and a demon spoiler
alert
that's why he couldn't keep it in his
pants because
he couldn't keep it in his pants too
because he was trying to manipulate
i don't know we'll get into that so like
i said it's a spoiler but like i said
this came out in 87.
so on the movie retrospectives i don't
really worry so much about spoil and
[ __ ]
and uh you know so just a little uh [ __ ]
out of the way so this actually is
um because i assumed when i when we were
watching it because i'd only seen pieces
of it i'd never
sat through the whole thing before um
that i was like well this must be based
on a book it is
uh it's based on a book which is called
blackguard
um and this is actually based on the
first book in the series there are six
in the series they were written by uh
hideyuki kikuchi
uh although this movie in particular
this adaptation
was the directorial debut a very famous
dude in anime if you know anything about
anime you'll know what this uh dude's
name is it's a yoshiaki kawajiri
who would later go on to do vampire
hunter d bloodlust he would do ninja
scroll
he would do like some really really well
known ones so on this one he was not
only the director but he also designed
the characters
he uh you know he did the storyboards uh
he was the animation director
and he also did a lot of the animation
himself
so this is kind of his project when they
first asked him to do it
it was actually supposed to be i guess
what they call over there an ova which i
think that's just like animation
that's just going to like direct to
video or direct to dvd or whatever
um but after he showed them is only
initially supposed to be 35 minutes long
but after he showed
you know a sample of it they liked it so
much
that they're like okay well can you
flesh it out to like 85 minutes and
we'll release it in the theater which
they did
um for a short time but that so that's
kind of why so
so maybe that might be why it has a
little bit of that strange like the
pacing is a little strange not that
strange compared to some other
i mean some other anime i've seen i'm
just like i'm like 10
15 minutes in and i'm like what in the
blue [ __ ] is going on in this [ __ ]
movie
that's the thing that stands out that's
the thing that stands out to me is that
the edit is good and the pacing is good
you can follow the story
yeah a lot of anime from this time and
even beyond
was just incomprehensible yeah and i
think a lot is lost in the translation
yeah maybe because i don't know you know
i don't read a lot of i don't you know i
don't read any manga i don't really
haven't seen a lot of anime so maybe if
you're super into it
um you know it's a lot easier for you to
parse because you know a lot about the
cultural context and all this other kind
of stuff so
i could follow appleseed you guys
probably know what apple seeded there
was
there was like a couple of movies called
appleseed i could follow it
but a lot of it didn't matter it was
just to show you something
you know mutant not genetically
engineered kitty girls you know
dancing around just weird [ __ ] you know
tanks and mecca and
there's another one that was uh tank
police i think it was apple seed tank
i get them all kind of confused they're
kind of samey but this one kind of has
its own
kind of tone it the tone is blade rudder
really
and it has a very blade runway kind of
look to it even the animation
i mean you know it looks like 1987
animation but it's
really nice animation like the way the
way that the um
the shots are framed very very
cinematically yeah it looks really good
position good at it
um if you like vaporwave videos that
have
anime going it's like that yeah that
same tone
and the uh soundscapes and the music was
good very very kind of vaporwave
yeah i liked it yeah so okay so the
story behind
this behind wicked city
is that it posits that there is the
human world that most people know about
and then there's also a world of
essentially sex demons sex demons
uh which is known as the black world
right
and you can have sex with them it's
supposed to be like mind-blowing sex
yeah but they kill you kind of like a
little bit of a
little bit of time they don't always
kill you but they just if they kind of
[ __ ] feel it so almost kind of like
hellraiser too
yeah a bit now that you mention it yeah
so
um so basically there are in the human
world and also uh
in the black world there are these uh
essentially black guards and they're
kind of like secret agents
i guess they have like normal jobs as a
cover but then
their job is to kind of keep because i
guess they say like there's a voice over
at the beginning and the main character
taki who is one of these black guard
characters
um he is kind of talking about how
there's been sort of an uneasy
uneasy truce between uh the black world
and the human world
for a thousand years i think he says um
and the tone is very
deckard slash double-oh-seven
yeah it's like a combination of the two
yeah he's like a secret agent and he has
and he works at like
like an electrician like he's a salesman
secret agent slash
private eye yeah kind of thing it's very
much like that yeah
so uh right from the jump though right
after you find out about his job and
about yeah there's two worlds and
there's like an uneasy truce and we're
trying to maintain that um but also
they're like i guess radicals as they
call them from the demon world that i
guess just want to come over here and
take over the [ __ ] so they always have
to watch out for that kind of [ __ ]
so pretty much as i said like right from
the outset you know what kind of movie
this is going to be because taki
is in a bar talking to a bartender and
he's like yeah man i've been trying to
butter this isn't exactly what he says
but he's been trying to like butter up
this
woman for three months or whatever and
trying to get laid um
and because he's kind of a player in
this movie he claims to be but you don't
really see that
you kind of do but well sorta yeah
well uh unbeknownst to him what has
happened is that his date
who he's at the bar with um has gone to
the bathroom
and another woman in there has killed
her or knocked her out or something they
don't really say i think she
just killed her yeah so because you just
see like a dead hand in there and then
the demon comes out looking like the
girl
yeah so she's kind of like hey tonight's
the night big boy you know and he's like
woo all right and so like they go
to his house or a hotel room or whatever
and uh you know they're [ __ ] and
whatnot and like i said it's pretty
porny
and uh then and i can't count the number
of times i've had this happen
yeah she turns into a spider yeah well
she attacked him with some tooth [ __ ]
a spider woman yeah yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] weird well you don't know
i mean i guess you do kind of know they
say this at the beginning but she took
his i don't think she didn't take his
entire dick because he did wasn't that
upset about it but
she took his uh jizz for sure yeah she
was trying to get pregnant
yeah because you don't like it like i
said you don't find that out
or why until later on i got you i got
what i came for and then she
she was she had a spider form looked
like a woman in the shape of a spider
but only four legs
yeah and like like her their wither
where their where their [ __ ]
stockings on and all their [ __ ] um
with their [ __ ] garter and everything
i know i was like wow those are pretty
good stockings
like a sex spider these are these are
like particularly made these particular
stockings
for women that turn into spiders after
sex i guess
and yeah like you said she has the
vagina dentata going on
with the tooth [ __ ] later on you see
she can shoot webs out of there
yeah hang from the ceiling and [ __ ]
can't i mean all women can do that
we're just we're just keeping it a
secret yeah but yeah
but yeah they've got to morph too you
know they're they're going to become
fluid when they need to they're not
they're not solid they're a lot like the
thing for they're a lot like the the
alien from the thing
yeah like you know tentacles bust out of
them like [ __ ]
iron bar rib cages come out and grab you
and [ __ ] like that
they can't infect you but i think they
can kind of infect each other
because that happened to that girl
remember he just jumped off and went up
their sleeve
oh yeah that's right it was like i guess
it i don't see i don't know if like all
the demons have the same powers because
they all have different looking [ __ ]
like some of them are like hey you got
these tentacles coming out of my chest
[ __ ]
some of them are like you know got a
tooth vagina
and spider legs and then some of them
were kind of like well you can cut my
head off but then i turn into like
bubbling green goo and i regenerate
myself you talk you try to shoot one of
them one time in the old sex
with the sex golem says no don't shoot
it you'll break it into a thousand
pieces and it'll just run off
yeah and then it'll like i don't know if
it'll make a whole bunch of them or
whatever yeah
yeah but so okay so after this whole
incident
what ends up happening is that taki
is given a new assignment by his boss
and he's like basically there is this as
we call him the sex column
it's this little person who looks like
looks like a person kind of looks like
gollum but yeah sort of like gollum he
has like a weird little
[ __ ] facial yeah with that kind of
thing going on
like you know the the dude from gremlins
that sold them the mogwai
dude's a [ __ ] he is and he's like a
little tiny like child size and he has
this really weird
um like sweat suit on like a little blue
like yeah he's dressed like a little
workout suit with little tennis shoes
yeah and he is annoying as [ __ ] but
there's a reason for that too because
the whole time
i'm watching and i'm sitting there going
what the [ __ ] is the deal it's like yeah
with this dude and everything
so this dude uh whose name what the [ __ ]
is his name
my art yeah um just giuseppe my art
that's his name he's like some kind of
diplomat
yeah and he is coming into town into
tokyo where this is set
and um he is supposed to like sign this
new treaty between human world and demon
world and he's
really really important so taki is
tasked with
protecting this [ __ ] because
apparently he's like some of the demon
radicals and stuff like that want to
kill him
yeah you know there's a plane blows up
and also they're like holy [ __ ] he was
on there the radicals got him but he was
already there because he's like hey man
i figured the [ __ ] out beforehand
so when he's at the airport you know
going there to pick this dude up
like he gets attacked by two radicals
and like all kind of
uh tentacle fun ensues and so i guess
at this point he is given another
partner
named uh makia and she is
from she's a black guard but she's from
the demon world yeah she's a sex demon
chick
yeah yeah with and her cover is a model
yeah she looks like a model yeah and he
gives her like all these
lines about how how annoyingly perfect
she is and all this other kind of stuff
she's got all these supernatural powers
biological powers and stuff
yeah that uh so they got to protect this
little giuseppe dude
he's part demon you don't really know
that until a bit later and he is just
like obviously laying it on think he's
been good stuff baby
he's trying to grab her ass constantly
yeah they're like in the car and i'm
sorry
he's telling me to take her to the
[ __ ] he wants to go to the escort
[ __ ] he wants to go
order escorts and [ __ ] he is like a
really sexually charged child
well he's like this little tiny
gremlin-like creature
and they're just supposed to they're
like look we're just supposed to protect
you
until tomorrow like when you sign the
ship because you're really important we
don't want you to get assassinated
and so like we have to take you to this
one particular hotel nobody else is
staying in the hotel it has like all
these demon
repelling [ __ ] around it or whatever
turns out dude's like 200 years old
he's like 200 years you'll find out
later yeah yeah he's super super rapey i
mean
you know because makia is like sitting
in the back seat and i'm sitting there
going
man if it was me i'd have been like hey
taki can i please sit in the front seat
instead of backwards it doesn't bother
hershey's handsy my hand
it doesn't bother her she's a sex demon
anyway
that's true you know talk about they
come from the sexes this is like yep
this is how [ __ ] goes
it's a hellish sexual dimension that
they come from yeah yeah
so she's like you know just getting
together getting your boob honked by a
sex column in the back seat of a car is
just like
no big i guess so they take him to this
hotel he is having a huge whiny fit
because
he has all these porno magazines like
escort mags and he's just like i want to
go to the [ __ ]
whatever they call a playboy club yeah
he wants to go to the playboy club and
you know get his dick wet or whatever
yeah which i think um i guess in
japanese parlance that's called soap
land
the blade yeah yeah so he wants to go to
one of those and they're just like no
shut up and just like go to sleep you're
we're supposed to be protecting you
but then um some of the demon radicals
somehow get into the hotel
attack taki and the this other guy he
was like the maitre d or the owner of
the hotel or
whatever he's he's one of them too that
he's a secret agent too that's kind of
what i thought but i did i wasn't real
clear on that
i think maybe he said it all the secret
agents controlled that whole hotel
from what i remember yeah yeah they
fight this
demon and then during that part
didn't um during that part the little
sex golem dude [ __ ] escapes out the
back and goes well yeah he climbs out
the window
and goes to soap land yeah they say they
show him and he's talking all this [ __ ]
with this
so oh so is there a sex scene with the
sex column oh yeah
kind of yeah it's not real graphic but
yeah
[Laughter]
it's it's funny though it's kind of like
comedic relief turns out she's a demon
too she turns into this down
she tries to absorb him she turns into a
[ __ ]
a pile of goo really she gets all gooey
and tries to suck him into her
[ __ ] belly remember it's yeah it's
something they were pulling and trying
to pull him out
and everything yeah because he's like
touching the boob and he's like oh it's
all melty like wax and he's like oh [ __ ]
and she's like she's
inside my body yeah she escapes to get
it back
they try to get take him to the car and
get attacked by another demon remember
yep that's right that demon captures the
uh the female
agent yeah from the other dimension and
then they uh
he he takes the takes the old sex golem
dude
takes him to a um where she took him to
um well he got hurt so they they had to
take him to this like clinic somewhere
right because that was you know they
can't just take him anywhere
using high technology on a fixed putting
him in a tank with a bunch of [ __ ]
during that time he
during that time talk he gets like a
psychic image in the damn ground of
of of of his ex partner she's being like
gang raped by all these demons
yeah there's a lot of rain it's like
bondage you know they got her all
handcuffed and [ __ ]
she's a demon too so i guess it's just
kind of normal for them they did
because every time you see one it's some
kind of sex d it's a sex demon
and they're in sex hell sex dimension i
mean the one and
i probably one of the most famous scenes
in this is her getting like um
the tentacle going in the mouth like
yeah there's it just do not
this children should not watch this is
animated but children should not watch
this
by any stretch of the event like i said
it's borderline born
so they said you know where you gonna
use her up and kill her
uh you can rescue her you can try to you
could rescue her if you want to try and
he was like yeah where is she i'll go
rescue her you know she's ready to give
her life and [ __ ] [ __ ] save the
client and save them
so the little green ball take takes him
to the location he was falling in the
car wasn't he
yeah yeah and he gets there and it's
just uh
a whole gang of damn demons and an
abandoned i it wasn't clear if it was in
another dimension or not
yeah i didn't really get that i don't
know if it was somewhere in this
dimension that they just i think it was
another dimension because they were like
showing it to him like in the
like a black pool on the sidewalk or
whatever he gets in there
[ __ ] gets a big fight with all these
demons to get her back
it's pretty cool he has a special demon
killing gun yeah and
the gun is kind of borrowed from blade
runner it's a revolver
it's a like a three to seven magnum but
it's got a real big heavy barrel
heavy barrel on it it's kind of
triangular and it's got some stuff in
there and it just shoots it down blue
ray bullet it's got rounds six rounds
and [ __ ]
look like three to seven magnum maybe 44
magnus something like that yeah
uh you could tell that they kind of
styled it after deckard's gone
yeah like i said the look of this is
very very blade running yeah
um and it's the the story is sort of
like blade runner
a little bit like just in in the kind of
you know
generality voice over like the uh the
old original edit of blade runner where
he's talking to himself like deckard
talking to himself yeah like that
or explaining to you what it is he's
doing what it is that's going on
right which i kind of appreciate because
when when a world is this
i don't know this one wasn't real
complicated compared to
like some other anime um it's this one's
fairly easy
to follow yeah but even then if you
didn't have the voiceover i'm not
entirely sure that i would know what was
going on
no you wouldn't i don't think i would
there's not enough dialogue in it yeah
so um so at this stage there's like a
huge fight
and then you think don't you at one
point you think so you know people's
arms get shot off the dude punches uh
dude like right
right through the face like all the way
through his head um you know it's pretty
rad
eyeballs popping out everywhere it's
it's pretty gross and
um so then at some point don't you think
that taki
and makia like you think they both get
killed
but then suddenly they wake up and
they're in a
weird church somewhere yeah that's right
you remember that it's all like oh
heaven they think they're in heaven or
it's like are we dead what's going on
well i don't know let's [ __ ] so they do
yeah because this is the first thing you
think
of taki's boss told him said don't
don't screw this chick yeah that's a
demon you know
you keep it in your pants type of deal
he did it anyway
and it turned out that uh they could
cross breed humans and demons could
cross
well they were the only two that could
do that in this generation that's why
they had been
manipulated because you find out at the
end spoiler alert that sex gollum
yeah uh you know the really an annoying
guy
everything that he had done in the movie
was to manipulate taki
into falling in love with makia and
impregnating her
yeah because these two they had
determined through their genetic
they somehow they knew what their
genetic like [ __ ] was and they're just
like these two are the only ones that
will be able to bear
um a half human half demon hybrid and
hopefully that will kind of help unify
yeah they're trying to make the peace
treaty to you know the peace treaty yeah
and then it was funny is that like
part of it you know they had like a
religious fetish going on because
the japanese you know if you know
japanese they're kind of crypto
christian a lot of them i've known a lot
of them that were kind of like that
because shinto doesn't really have a
concept of like a centralized god
is in an afterlife in in the way that
christianity does they're kind of crypto
christian and they kind of fetishize it
even though they don't quite understand
well they like all the imagery they like
the imagery and they like the concept
and that they get confused sometimes
you'll see
[ __ ] like christmas and christianity
mixed together like
like santa claus on a cross you'll see
[ __ ] like
if i could find a [ __ ] toy of that
i'm just putting that i'm gonna put that
on the front door at christmas time
someone will set her house on fire i
haven't seen that in a long time i don't
know if the japanese people that did it
were joking or not
but i was just like i kind of suspect
they were because like for a time i
thought maybe that was an urban legend
or somebody was just kidding
no but i don't really know there's some
kind of crossover between jesus
and and christmas so i mean you can see
why that happened
anyway in this story they have to get
married in a
ceremony and it's a christian ceremony
that was part of the
the sex magic yeah so there's kind of
like fetishized christianity going on in
this
it's like along with tentacles along
with tentacle parts this is a trip yeah
and chess [ __ ]
but yeah not two spider vaginas
yeah and you know and people punching
through other people's heads it's all
it's fun for the whole family is what
i'm saying
it's really not and then you know
melting
prostitute boobies yeah all kind of [ __ ]
that
i think you know what i think that was
probably my favorite scene was that i
don't know why it's just
there was something i really liked about
that little [ __ ] sex golem being like
yay boobies and then he's like oh no and
then he was getting all like [ __ ] she
was all like half melted like a [ __ ]
candle or something
like that this has so if you i mean if
you've never seen any anime
this might be as long as you know what
you're getting into because like i said
this is borderline porn so don't like
like kids watching or nothing like that
because they're pretty [ __ ] up
there's a pretty [ __ ] up imagery in
this yeah uh a lot of it very very
sexual there's a lot of rape
uh there's a just it's you know it's
just like really and
like i said it's not so shocking
nowadays because you know we have the
internet and everyone's seen everything
but 1987 i can imagine that this was
kind of like when
kids in the u.s particularly probably
saw it they were probably like what the
[ __ ]
just you know what i mean i remember
that era
you know in the late 80s you know when
you're in your late teens
japanese anime seemed very very adult
yeah especially compared to what you
were used to in terms of american
animation yeah because you didn't really
get other than heavy metal and
fire and ice and stuff yeah it was hard
to find yeah you didn't get a lot of
american or north american
animation that was geared toward at all
even though at my age i look at it a lot
of shit's really [ __ ] juvenile
it is a lot of the ideas for the
juvenile but i think it was kind of
aimed at the japanese male
audience between like 16 and 18. that's
probably what it was kind of aimed at
maybe early 20s i don't know which
probably same as
say heavy metal yeah it was aimed toward
like teenage guys yeah late teenage
years yeah yeah or like early 20s guys
right which same kind of thing but even
even by that standard though i mean
heavy metal is
kind of smutty you know there's big
titties and stuff
yeah this had to be what are you talking
about yeah but i mean wicked city this
is a whole
this is a whole other kettle of fish
it's like is it sexy
i don't well depends on what you're into
i guess i'm not judging
the heavy heavy metal the heavy metal
animated movie
was uh like i said it it was r-rated it
wasn't x-rated it was r-rated yeah
the i remember as a kid the heavy metal
magazines that you could buy that
they're illustrated yeah i remember they
were comic book magazines they were
thick you know
weren't really a dc comic book these
things were full color high quality
i haven't seen one a long time they were
[ __ ] very sexual and very violent but
they were well
really well done they had cool stories
some of them went along for [ __ ] many
issues
um you know so i think some of them were
broken up and put in i think
i think yeah uh what was the name wren
right now what was his name that den dan
yeah dan was in
in the one that you had yet yeah i think
that was broken up and put into heavy
metal there's a bunch of other
really good ones you know [ __ ] war
type [ __ ] happening in the future
but uh i'd probably say that
japanese anime when it got
got to this level it was way ahead in
terms of like it was acceptable it was
like border and hentai [ __ ]
and heavy metal wouldn't go that far
that's what i'm saying i feel like they
mostly they showed some sex and like big
tits and all that kind of stuff
but they wouldn't um i mean this is just
like
nightmarish yeah you know uh you know
i don't think in heavy metal they would
have shown like a woman with a
with a tooth vagina that shot spider
webs out of it no
and in heavy metal they wouldn't
actually show sex they would just kind
of suggest it a little bit
yeah it wasn't graphic it was kind of
like uh
playboy yeah level yeah you know not
even hustler
and it was all illustrated everything
was supposed to be you know amazing
proportions on [ __ ] the men and the
women
yeah man because it was fantasy yeah
yeah but i mean i mean i guess this is
too this this is two but like i said
this
yes it's perverted fans yeah and i don't
mean that like in a derogatory way
i'm just saying so you know what you're
getting into it's very sci-fi it's very
horror there's a lot of horrific imagery
and a lot of it is sexually charged
deviant too and it's yeah so that so
that's what i mean so
so i don't think you would have seen
that especially not in eight nineteen
seven right uh in the united states not
by a long stretch
but uh interestingly something that i
didn't really know that much about
i saw it on the wikipedia page that in
1992 there was actually a live action
sort of a remake of this even though the
story is kind of different um called the
wicked city
now i didn't get a chance to watch it
but i did watch uh brandon tennold did a
breakdown of it it looks
really it looked dumb as hell dumb yeah
um well the thing about it it seemed
like the story at first was kind of the
same
uh because they're like look they have a
dude named taki and he's you know
a black guard or whatever although in
the anime he's kind of like a big bull
like
and a little bit of a player like i said
or you know at least he seems kind of
slick and smooth
more than anything um in the live action
when he was kind of dorky
um also the after the initial
setup they don't do the whole thing
about
uh you know having with the diplomat or
anything like that
their whole thing is there's this drug
that came from the other dimension
and i think the people in the other
dimension are called reptars
rather than demons or black guard or
whatever they call them
i think they're called reptiles or
something like i've seen some great
something to do with that
and uh the special effects in it not
good
and there is some sex in it but it's not
nearly as explicit
uh as the anime it didn't it
i don't know it just it didn't look that
great and honestly brandon was saying
and he watches a lot of anime
he's like you know wicked city as an
anime is like actually the
animated one is actually pretty
straightforward and like fairly easy to
follow as long as you're like listen to
what everyone's saying
and he's like but this one the
live-action one he's like i had no
[ __ ]
idea what was going on um so it's just
really really strangely
edited there's just like all kind of
crazy [ __ ] going on um and like i said i
didn't really even know it existed until
i
had seen the other one uh and it but it
looks pretty bad
i haven't read any books or anything so
i don't know how closely it used to the
source material
but uh yeah if you if you don't mind
watching an english dub i'm sure you can
probably find the japanese one somewhere
and i'm sure that that's
uh superior because it always is but
if you're interested and like i said if
you've never seen any anime and want to
see some weird like
tentacle rape which like i said i'm not
judging um
it's just not acceptable but [ __ ] wasn't
acceptable then and it isn't acceptable
now but
you they had it anyway that was the
whole idea it was it's basically a [ __ ]
you
yeah i mean and and and in defense of
heavy metal
heavy metal would have was kind of tame
in comparison to this
yeah but heavy metal still wasn't tame
it was no
it was good it was good it's just the
tastes the tastes were different
you know it's not japanese people making
these stories it's americans so
it's gonna have an american flavor um
so you know i'm just trying to stand up
for heavy but heavy metal wasn't [ __ ]
well it was doing a different it was
just a different thing right yeah and
the thing about it is like i'm not
really sure because i'm not from japan
i'm not really sure how acceptable i
mean obviously like little kids wouldn't
be watching this or they wouldn't be
showing it on regular tv like back in
1987
but it does seem to me that it was a lot
more acceptable
culturally i mean i i don't remember
reading anything about it getting
censored particularly or anything like
that
has a much japan has a much higher
[ __ ] tolerance to anything that we
would consider
perversion i mean they have they their
porn industry is [ __ ] giant and
includes things that were not legal here
yeah you know what i mean so and
evidently it's not
real low-key you know what i mean so
everybody knows
yeah that was kind of all that was
always really wasn't you know this this
really wouldn't be all that
controversial controversial just what i
was thinking
right yeah because here i if you just
showed this somewhere in 1987 everyone
would come after you with pitchforks
probably
but yeah it's on to be for free the
english dub is if you're interested
you should definitely go check it out uh
but like i said i'm not a
huge anime fan but i'm actually really
glad i saw it because it's actually
pretty cool
you know the animation looks pretty cool
it's like the imagery is really cool
really horrific and uh you know i i kind
of dug it i don't know if i'm going to
be watching a lot more anime because
like i said
some of it is a little bit most of it's
mediocre just got to say the
storytelling is mediocre on a lot of it
yeah
but i mean if you really liked you know
[ __ ] like vampire hunter d
or you know ninja scroll or something
like that which and if you want to see
where that guy kind of started out
then this would be a good thing to watch
and you can like i said if you're in the
us you can watch it on tv for free
so uh go and check it out it's called
wicked city and uh we'll see you on the
next one
bye